[Music]
some troubling developments tonight
surrounding congresswoman
omar amid new revelations about swampy
campaign spending practices
here to explain more are chief breaking
news correspondent trace gallagher
tonight trace
sean when congresswoman elon omar was
first accused of having an affair with
political consultant tim mynet
by mynet's then wife omar vehemently
denied it
now she and mynet are married and the
new york post says omar continues
funneling money
into her new husband's political
consulting firm
in fact records show that since 2018
omar
has paid my net more than 878
thousand dollars including 189 thousand
dollars just a few months ago
the federal election commission allows
lawmakers to hire their spouse but
political experts and ethics lawyers
call it political cronyism at its finest
so elon omar isn't just tim mynet's new
wife
she's his firm's biggest customer and at
one point
one in every three of elon omar's
campaign dollars
was going to my net's firm sean
all right trace thank you very much